hey what's up guys my name is eternal
welcome to episode 10 the tenth
wonderful episode glorious episode of
game programming so yesterday we drew a
pixel to the screen right here and what
I wanted one wanna do today is actually
show you guys how to amend a problem so
we have this pixel and we could change
coordinates you know live to say I don't
know 100 and you can see that it draws
the new one but the old one still
remains in the actual on the actual
screen it doesn't get a raise and the
reason for that being is this black
background that you see isn't really
like a black solid what it actually is
is just a void it's an empty space that
we haven't actually filled with anything
now that's a problem because what
happens is when we move something yeah
it kind of doesn't work that way all
right we can't just simply reposition
something or animate something and then
expect the old part to go away what we
actually need to do is clear the screen
every time we update our how else create
our image now to demonstrate this
further what I could do is actually
animate the position the pixels so right
now I'm just gonna quickly and I'll
erase this code in a second but I can
make it a variable called time set it
equal to zero and then say that okay you
don't need to take this code down I'm
literally just using it just to just to
show you guys what an animation would
look like so oops
all right so if I am
something like along the lines of this
you can actually see that it's going
down right now across the screen but
obviously it's not kidding it's not
getting removed and will crash
eventually want to go to the screen but
we'll talk about that in another episode
and I'll make this time as well so we
get a nice diagonal line so yeah you can
see right now it's gone diagonally
across the screen but the old position
isn't getting removed we're animating
but will that were actually leaving a
trail and that's because we're not
raising the screen so that's what we're
gonna do today we're actually gonna
learn about how how we can clear the
screen so the way we can do that is very
simple I'm just gonna make a new method
in this screen class called clear so
public void clear and inside this method
remember this is in the screen class all
we need to do is create a for loop that
will cycle through every pixel in our
pixel array and just set it to black set
it to zero so for and I equals zero is
less than pixels length so again that
will make sure that this for loop I plus
plus pixels at length will make sure
that this for loop will actually cycle
through every one of our elements in our
pixel integer array and we're he's gonna
hit pixels I April 0 so again these
three lines of code will this one line
of this for loop will set every pixel in
our pixel array to black to zero so now
that we've created this in the screen
class we actually need to run it so back
in our game class I'm gonna go I'm gonna
scroll down to our random method and in
this random method before we rendered
the screen make sure you don't do it
after we're just gonna call screen dot
clear so what's going to do every time
it comes up here it clears the screen
and then it renders our image on top of
that clear screen not the other way
around if we did it this way
what happen is it we it would actually
render the image and then clear it and
then show it so we just get a black
screen so make sure that it's here
because remember it is doing it in
chronological order we wanted to clear
the screen because what will happen is
we render an image on to the screen we
get we show it we go to the bottom we go
to the top because it's in a loop right
in this wild running loop we go back to
the top that that image is still there
and then if this wasn't there we'd
render it again on top of the old image
but this way the old image gets to the
bottom the old image is still going up
the old image gets cleared and then
we're entering onto a fresh canvas so
that's what happens so now if I actually
just run it you'll see that that one
pixel now is traveling with no residue
with not with nothing behind it because
it's a it's simply just traveling to the
bottom to the bottom of the screen and
if I am set this back to what it was
just so you can see the vertical
movement are me
it's simply travelling across the across
the screen I actually like the diagonal
more so yeah there it is that one pixel
is now traveling across our image and
across our canvas and it's fine the
other problem is we actually crash when
we get to the bottom because it
generates an arraigned X out of bounds
exception now what is an array index out
of bounds exception you'll find that out
tomorrow a lot of guys
you
[Music]